>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE LEAD.
WE ARE SPEAKING WITH
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
DONALD TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN MANAGER
TURNED WHITE HOUSE COUNSELOR.
>> MM-HMM.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HIS
FIRST FOREIGN TRIP MAY BE TO
MEET WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ISN'T THAT TROUBLING?
>> ACTUALLY, NO, IT'S NOT.
AND THE THING TO REMEMBER ABOUT
RUSSIA IS THAT WE WON AND I
DON'T KNOW WHY YOU KEEP
BRINGING UP THE ELECTION.
>> I'M NOT.
I'M TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA.
DOESN'T TRUMP'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH PUTIN CONCERN YOU?
>> ACTUALLY WHAT DOES CONCERN ME
IS THAT SHE DIDN'T GO TO
MICHIGAN, SHE LOST AND WE WON
AND WE DID WIN.
>> OH MY GOD, WHY DO YOU DO
THIS?
>> DO WHAT, JAKE?
>> COME ON HERE EVERY SINGLE DAY
AND DO THIS.
WHAT DO YOU GET OUT OF THIS?
>> I LOVE TRUMP.
AND I BELIEVE IN TRUMP.
AND THE REASON I JOINED THE
CAMPAIGN, IS BECAUSE I THOUGHT
HE WAS GOING TO BE THE PRESIDENT
FOR ALL PEOPLE.
>> REALLY?
THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU THOUGHT?
>> MM-HMM, YES, THAT'S WHAT I
THOUGHT.
>> YES, THAT'S ALL YOU THOUGHT?
>> WELL --
♪♪♪
>> I GUESS IF I'M BEING
COMPLETELY HONEST, JAKE, I JUST
ALSO THINK --
♪ WHAT'S THE NAME ON
EVERYBODY'S LIST ♪
♪ GOT TO BE CONWAY ♪
♪ THE LADY RAKING IN THE
CHIPS IS GONNA BE ♪
♪ CONWAY ♪
♪ I'M GONNA BE A
CELEBRITY
THAT MEANS SOMEBODY
EVERYONE KNOWS ♪
♪ THEY'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
MY EYES MY HAIR MY NOSE
OOH I'M GOING TO JOIN ♪
♪ NOT JUST SOME DUMB
BLUEBERRY FARM
I'M GONNA BE CONWAY ♪
♪ WHO SAYS LYING'S NOT AN
ART ♪
♪ AND WHEN THEY GOOGLE JUST
OKAY ♪
♪ MY NAME WILL COME UP BEFORE
KANYE ♪
♪ KELLYANNE CONWAY ♪
[ GIGGLES ]
>> NOW, KELLYANNE, STARTING
YESTERDAY, YOU ARE NOW COUNSELOR
TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> YES, I AM, I AM THAT.
>> YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT'S EAR
AND A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO EFFECT
CHANGE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> OH, MY GOD, JAKE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THIS MEANS?
BOYS --
♪ THEY'RE GONNA WAIT OUTSIDE
IN LINE TO GET TO SEE
CONWAY ♪
♪ THINK OF THOSE AUTOGRAPHS I'LL
SIGN ♪
♪ GOOD LUCK TO YOU ♪
♪ CONWAY ♪
♪ AND I'LL APPEAR IN A
SLEEVELESS DRESS ON ANY
SHOW THEY'LL LET ME DO ♪
♪ MEET THE PRESS, ANDERSON ♪
♪ IF THEY CALL I'LL DO THE
CHEW ♪
♪ OOH, I'M A STAR ♪
♪ AND THE AUDIENCE LOVES ME ♪
♪ AND I LOVE THEM AND THEY
LOVE ME FOR LOVING THEM AND I
LOVE THEM FOR LOVING ME AND
WE LOVE EACH OTHER ♪
HEY, KNOW WHAT'S WEIRD?
THIS TIME LAST YEAR I SUPPORTED
TED CRUZ.
I SAID DONALD TRUMP ACTED
UNPRESIDENTIAL.
IT'S ON TAPE.
BUT HEY, THAT'S SHOW BIZ, KIDS.
♪ SHE'S GIVING UP HER
HUMDRUM LIFE ♪
♪ I'M GONNA BE ♪
♪ CONWAY ♪
♪ SHE TREATS THE NEWS JUST
LIKE A PLAY ♪
♪ AND WHEN THE WORLD GOES UP IN
FLAMES ♪
♪ AT LEAST FOR NOW THEY KNEW
MY NAME
KELLYANNE CONWAY ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]